[Music]
every day you get a chance to be alive
and every day you get this chance you
should attempt to make the most of what
you do with it so as the light takes its
temporary intermission and you prepare
to drift away into the dream state of
your mind take a moment to consciously
reflect ask yourself what did i do today
am I happy with what I did
should I have done more should I have
done less could I have done what I did
differently to make it more enjoyable
more beautiful more engaging think about
whether or not you let yourself fully
engage in the beauty of this life ask
yourself did I add beauty or take it
away then ask what can I do tomorrow to
make and add a little more beauty
[Music]
sit with these questions for a little
while let them hang in your head
[Music]
now let them go except that the day is
now over and regardless of how good or
bad it may have seemed let it go and
give yourself the credit you deserve the
credit for caring about your life for
wanting to ask these questions the
credit for surviving a full day on this
planet in this uncertain reality the
fact that you can even understand what
life and beauty is that you can even ask
these questions all justifies your
worthiness of acquiring their best
answers worthiness of feeling success
bliss and gratitude in your life so
before you completely relinquish the
remaining pieces of your awareness to
the night take one last moment to
remember to thank the wonder that is
your life take a moment to be thankful
for the people that you have encountered
today the things you experienced and the
concepts you learned and finally be
thankful that you can close your eyes
and go to sleep
knowing that tomorrow you will wake up
alongside the Sun and get another chance
to write more of your story
you
[Music]